It's crazy to me that after almost five years of marriage,
this is the first time I'm gonna see Lucky Walk a fashion show.
Who better to do that with than Ralph Lauren?
Were showing in the Hamptons,
so we got up very early, got in the car,
drove for about two hours before making it.
First thing we obviously had to do was grab some lunch,
and I'm so bummed out that tomato season is gonna be over soon.
I didn't have time for dessert,
since I had to rush back and start on glam.
They were so nice to bring me my two scoops of ice cream.
I needed. I always need something sweet to finish the meal.
We went for something very elegant and simple today,
and I was obsessed with how this look turned out.
Before I left, I fed whimsy,
took some content, and then it was time to head over to the location.
It was set on this beautiful property
with all these horses and stables.
Right when I got there, I did some Ralph Lauren content,
obviously also did one of my voice overs.
And then it was time for the show to start.
All the clothes were beautiful.
I couldn't get enough of the fabrics and the fit of everything.
I was obviously the most excited to see lucky walk,
and when he came out, my heart started pounding.
And then he winked at me, and I was trying so hard to Hold it together.
I couldn't get enough of how beautiful all the clothes were.
And when the kids came out,
I tried not to cry. This show made me so emotional.
It was probably one of the most beautiful shows I've been at.
After the show, we did all the interviews,
took some pictures and then sat down for an iconic dinner.
I got the burger because I knew lucky would wanna share with me.
And then it was time to head home.